تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه هجومها المضاد
حيث نفذت ضربه صاروخيه على المقر العام
للاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود والواقع
في وسط مدينه سيباستوبول في القرم شن
العدو هجوما صاروخيا على المقر العام
للاسطول في البحر الاسود يجري تحديد حصيله
الضحايا المحتملين وهناك احتمال بوقوع
هجوم اوكراني
اخر وزاره الفاع الروسيه كانت قد اعلنت في
وقت سابق عن تدمير طائرتين سيارتين قرب
ساحل القرم وفي منطقه توابسي باقليم
كراسنودار الهجمات تتواصل ايضا على جبهه
بموت التي استهدفتها القوات الاوكرانيه
بقصف عنيف وصفه رئيس العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في المنطقه
بالفوضي خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه نفذ
العدو عددا من العمليات في اتجاه ليمان
ونفذ استطلاعا قتاليا في عده اتجاهات دفعه
واحده تقع ليمان على مسافه قريبه جدا من
خط مواجهه على بعد 50 كيل مترا غرب لسيت
شانس وسفير دونيتسك وهما مدينتان تحت
السيطره الروسيه المنطقه الصناعيه عانت من
وطاه القتال منذ الهجوم الروسي وتعد معركه
باخ موت الاطول والاكثر دمويه في الصراع
من جهه اخرى قالت الشركه المشغله للطاقه
في اوكرانيا ان هجمات صاروخيه روسيه الحقت
اضرارا بالبنيه التحتيه للطاقه في وسط
وغرب اوكرانيا وتسببت في انقطاعات
للكهرباء في خمس مناطق رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني ادان استئناف روسيا ما وصفه
بارهاب الطاقه من خلال مهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه الاساسيه مع اقتراب فصل
الشتاء الى